what would you advise Sony to do right
now well I think the first consideration
is less of a legal one in a business
consideration and figuring out a way to
recoup the investment and I believe
there's been some talk about releasing
the movie video on demand and trying to
find a way to recoup partially that
investment on the other end of this
Sony's going to want to look to people
like mr. Lieberman to help them try to
ascertain the identity of the hackers
and figure out who's responsible for
this including whether there are any
potential former insiders that may have
been involved on the legal side they're
already facing a couple of lawsuits with
respect to the disclosure of the
information so certainly they're going
to have to give due consideration to
those claims and probably some more Phil
Lieberman let's say that you get a call
from the head of Sony right after this
program what do you tell them to do
about their systems so it's a great
question pop come the we're actually
talking to Sony at this point in time so
it's kind of a coincidence we actually
do secure the other studios the issue
really has to do with the nature of how
well they're handling passwords and how
well they're handling accounts within
their environment it's been a pretty
major breach to pretty much win across
everything that they own Phil Lieberman
did Sony follow the correct protocols
when it comes to unveiling and releasing
the information related to the hack
attack so you know there's really no
protocols to this this is really an
unprecedented type of an attack the
escalation that it took yesterday with
regard to actually threatening patrons
and threatening exhibitors of the movie
it's really without precedent at all if
you go back and take a look at some of
the ransomware attacks that involve
money and extortion
nobody has ever threatened physical
violence as an outcome so this one's
different this one doesn't really follow
any other pattern that we've seen before
Devon McCray is it possible that Sony
has insurance that would cover let's say
the 44 million dollars that they spent
to create the film it's possible there
are insurance coverage for productions
and it's all going to depend on the
language of the policy that they have
Phil Lieberman what would you suggest to
the actors and to all the professionals
involved in making this movie about the
future of their online life well you
know you've certainly seen the attacks
on these celebrities with regard to
their cell phones and their information
getting compromised I do believe there
was some disclosure with regard to Sony
having some cyber security insurance
already that should cover part of it in
addition to that their auditors
themselves would probably face some of
the liability in this so consequently
the outcome of discovery with recent
lawsuits probably going to surface the
amount of disclosure that their auditors
provided them as to how good a job they
were actually doing with security and
how compliant they were with industry
standards Devon is there anything that
the individuals affected by this attack
can now do when it comes to potential
personal liability well certainly the
individuals that have been harmed by
this may be looking to for the results
of the audits with respect to Sony's
handling of the information some of them
may be looking to Sony to sue them for
not exercising reasonable standards of
care and protecting their information
and possibly their financial interests
in the movie Phil the theatres
exhibitors AMC Regal they've decided of
course not to show the movie are they
giving in to a form of online terrorism
so you know it's interesting discussion
we've had today with a lot of different
entities regarding this and probably
have in the US legal system is that if
there is a public threat to life and
property and one of the exhibitors puts
on the event or puts on the film when
something bad happens even if it wasn't
terrorism they really can be facing some
pretty serious liability so consequently
probably figuring that it's too hot of a
potato to be holding on to there's
better things to do Devon what does this
mean for other movie studios as well as
Sony when they decide to make future
pictures that might annoy some of the
objects well I think that's a major
concern is whether this is going to
chill creative expression and whether
now you're going to have Studios
deciding that they're just not going to
make movies because they're concerned
somebody's going to be upset by it
Phil Lieberman last point to you
executives at Sony are they going to
have to change their profile not only
online but how they deal with
individuals as a result of everybody
learning their personal email comments
so you know there's a lesson to be
learned on this which has to do really
with security on the internet that is
essentially that nobody is really all
that secure that your email your store
documents your pictures pretty much
everything is really in play if you
really want to be protected you don't
put it online the executives are going
to need to change their profile
certainly but there's even a bigger
question about CEOs and the nature of
what their role is in terms of IT
security so beyond just the financials
there's a there's a bigger question I
think that needs to be asked as to whose
job it is to actually provide security
at the studios and in the broader
question with regard to other
corporations what's the responsibility
of the CEO in general security